Can I use organic coffee from the health food store or should I use the gold roast coffee for coffee animals?
Yeah, so let's say you run out of gold rose. What's the benefit of the gold rose over this regular organic coffee?
Well, the gold rose has higher caffeine levels. That's the whole thing
The difference between gold rose and this organic coffee that you have the organic coffee that you have is roasted
And the longer you roast it, the less caffeine you have in the coffee
The gold roast is hard is very lightly roasted. You can't buy you if you you made a pot of coffee out of the gold roast coffee
End of a coffee. It would be gross tasting. You would not like the coffee. It's a near green coffee. So it's not
So it's the amount of caffeine that you're getting is the biggest thing
So but you can't so I tell people people are like, oh, I don't I can't you know, I tried it one of the gold roasts
I don't you know, I won't get it for a week because they might live far away or something. I just go just go buy some organic coffee and use that
So absolutely use it. Don't don't not do a coffee animal because you don't have the coffee at a coffee
so